[Music]
hey
the hell day is it it's monday it's
monday
don't sound so enthusiastic tom sleepy
i'm [ __ ] sleeping
sleeping i slept all night cat jumped on
me at like five o'clock in the morning
yeah she jumped on me too
yeah it's you know she does she does
that thing where she's just kind of like
hey it seems like it's been such a long
time are you guys awake yet yeah and
then you like you peek out of the
blanket and her big old black eyes are
looking at you she's looking at you
got a cat that wakes you up it's time to
get up
it's like here i'm going to make some
biscuits on your shoulder
yeah that's kind of what she does all
right so uh
you did you saw like the last half of
this movie i think
yeah right yeah yeah it was a good movie
i i would have liked to see
the whole thing but
okay you got to be ready for this kind
of movie it's a it's a painful movie
kind of like joker
you know we're joking you're watching a
dude go [ __ ] crazy and you're like
going man you know
bad [ __ ] happens
i liked it though it was kind of like a
uh it was a low budget movie but it was
done right
it was i gotta say i would go so far to
say i loved this movie
i thought it was fantastic it kind of in
certain ways kind of reminded me of
video drone
it did have a little bit of that vibe to
it didn't it yeah it's kind of like
video drama joker had a baby
with just other [ __ ] what platform is
this uh it's on hulu
that's where we watched it it might be
on amazon prime too i'm not entirely
sure but we watched it
uh we watched it on it it's worth
watching it's good yeah so it's gotta be
in the mood for it yeah so this came out
this year 2020 um it's called rent a pal
it's weird because a while back we
watched the trailer for it a long time
ago like when we were looking for new
movies to watch and i was like oh that
looks like a possibility because that
looks like pretty good
and then we just for whatever reason we
never got around to watching it
and then last night it was kind of
between this one and one other one on
hulu and i was like i think i'm kind of
more in the
psychological horror kind of mood and
that one looked kind of cooler so
the word the other one was kind of more
a horror comedy so i was so i started
watching it and i was immediately like
sucked in so the story behind this one
um will wheaton is in it and
uh brian landis focus they're kind of
the two main characters now this was
uh written directed and edited
by a dude named john stevenson i'm not
sure if this is the first movie or not
but it's if it is it's like wow dude
okay good job
but um so it's set in 1990
i thought it was the late 80s but it's
1990.
so basically you got brian landis focus
he's playing this dude
named david now david seems like i mean
he seems like a sweet like a nice enough
dude but
he's a little bit pitiful in the sense
that
he's 40 years old um he looks a lot
older
yeah he's kind of like very hang dog and
very kind of schlubby
yeah um you know and he has kind of been
forced by life into living in his mom's
basement his mom has dementia
and there's nobody else in the family to
take care of her and all this other kind
of [ __ ] he's so he can't work he's
basically her full-time caregiver
and he you know definitely has a little
bit of resentment about that
but he's a good guy at heart at least at
first
now since it's 1990 and tinder and the
internet and [ __ ] like that weren't
really a thing yet
he uh subscribes to this weird video
dating service call i think it's called
video rendezvous or something like that
things were [ __ ] horrible i know and
this was a real thing like that people
did it was like a whole service you
would go into a little studio
and they would film a video of you
talking about yourself
and then they would put all the clips
together and you would go and kind of
like you'd rent the video you'd go home
and watch it and then
there was a little booklet and you'd
fill out it's like a video rental
[ __ ] store but it was just people
trying to hook up
and they were expensive back in the day
and it was all [ __ ] middle-aged
people
losers and [ __ ] and over the years you
know i mean those places went out of
business
well yeah because in 1990 average
it was just starting to be where a video
a camcorder was
an average person could buy one uh they
were still you know
in 1990 you could get one for probably
about a cheap one
about 350 bucks but these stores would
get one about for you know a little 500
one you know
and and you could you could have a whole
business around videotaping
[ __ ]
and putting them up on vhs tapes and
you know they paid like a hundred
dollars to join and then a certain you
know probably like a hundred dollars a
month to [ __ ] go in there and rent
these
things and when they all went out of
business
over time those businesses you know they
had all those tapes
and they've kind of leaked out onto the
internet you can find them
they're [ __ ] pitiful [ __ ] some
people would like go through a whole
production
they'd dress up and go through a skit
and [ __ ]
reading lines it's just man [ __ ] was
cringy as [ __ ]
well i think they i think they really
nailed that with this
actually 1990 hair and [ __ ] weird you
know just
people were [ __ ] weird man back then
i didn't remember them being that weird
but i guess they were just weird on
camera
it's really weird whenever we watch some
[ __ ] from
1990 like because we've seen like some
dead mall videos that had footage from
1990 or movies from 1990
and i'm like god damn i forgot how 80s
than 1990s
and the 80s and the night in the 80s
were still kind of 70s people forget
that they were
so there was kind of and another thing
that was weird
is um looking back on it how
uncomfortable everyone was
on video because you you you never
really
it was rare yeah it wasn't something
anyone was used to nowadays because of
phones you know how many people get real
comfortable
well yeah now because everybody's videos
having themselves like all the time
like hey look i'm sitting on the can you
know what i mean
like anybody can be real comfortable in
front of a huge crowd i mean you know
they got guys like a stream and they got
300 000
people [ __ ] watching the stream and
the dudes just yeah whatever yeah
[ __ ] try that on stage you'd [ __ ]
freeze up in stage fright
but uh just people are and then and it's
funny because like some of the
professional actors we grew up with
they can't handle social media like
johnny depp
he tried to stream himself and he just
looked awkward as [ __ ]
yeah well it's two different different
platforms yeah it's kind of two
different things i mean the thing like
the [ __ ] that we do and the thing that a
lot of you
of people that are on youtube that
people like and relate to
is is that the people seem like real
people you know what i mean well we are
real people you know
this is this is what we're like like all
the time putting anything
can't be a real person [ __ ] live he's
trying to go
be he's trying to be johnny dip
and and the awkwardness is just cringy
it doesn't it doesn't translate to 2020.
well what are you gonna do yeah but yeah
so so this poor dude
it's in one of the best scenes and i
don't think that you saw this one but he
was actually going because
he he keeps like hoping that he's gonna
get matched with somebody but it's been
six months he's been a
member and he hasn't gotten matched with
any women yet so he kind of calls and
they're like well we see that you
haven't made a new video in six months
and maybe you should come and make a new
video and we'll put you back in
circulation and stuff
so he goes down there to do it and the
first one that he does
is actually pretty good like he goes on
and it seems really heartfelt and
everything
and then the guy behind the the thing is
like okay um
that was fine but it can only be 30
seconds long and he's like 30 seconds
long he's like i
i've watched people's you know the
women's once they're longer than that
he's like oh yeah well the women get a
lot longer because
there aren't as many women it's like we
have so many guys
that come in here to do it that we have
to keep them to 30 seconds otherwise
like the tapes would be [ __ ] nine
hours long
so then it's so then of course he only
has 30 seconds so he has to like make it
shorter and it's that it's like
sounds really really terrible uh i live
with my mother and
i want you to take care of me and you
know what i mean it was like but it
sounded good before
so he does that and he still doesn't get
any matches for a while now while he's
in the
in the place you know this little center
or whatever
he sees this bin that has all these
video tapes in it and he sees one in
there that's called
rent a pal and he's for whatever reason
he decides he's going to buy it or rent
it i guess you buy it because he doesn't
take it back
now this rent-a-pal video i love
that in the movie they don't explain who
this dude is
why he made this video or why any of it
you know what i mean
it's just this really weird video with
[ __ ] will wheaton
in a [ __ ] v-neck sweater
being as creepy as [ __ ] possible he's
kind of like mr rogers
but a really really creepy version like
he's super
overly nice and overly and the
the tape is so weird it's just him
sitting in a chair
and with a little phone a little lamp
and everything and he's talking to you
as though he's really talking to you
like he asks you questions and he leaves
a gap
so you can answer and it's like the
weirdest [ __ ] ever
so i guess he kind of rented it as a
lark and then he starts watching it and
at first he thinks it's he's like this
is this [ __ ] stupidest weirdest [ __ ]
i've ever seen which it is
but the more that he watches it he kind
of gets
sucked into it and he starts to like
david starts to think
that i mean i guess his
sense of reality starts to skew a little
bit where he thinks that this
that will wheaton whose character's name
is andy on the tape
is actually talking to him and actually
is his only friend
this is that's the part that's kind of
reminded me of video drawing yeah it's
like a video drone vibe to it
where the tv is talking back to you yeah
yeah
it's pretty weird and i like that they
kind of leave never explain it they
leave it ambiguous like i said they
leave it ambiguous you know why did
andy make this video um you know why was
it there
what's going on with it you know who is
this guy they don't go into his
backstory or anything like that it's the
only time you see him is on this
videotape that you know david starts
playing over and over because he starts
getting obsessed with it
and and they also leave it kind of
ambiguous
i guess i guess you could say they leave
it ambiguous whether
the videotape has some kind of weird
uh like paranormal like or supernatural
kind of
power to it or whether david is just
projecting his own you know uh
escalating madness onto it maybe like
he's starting to perceive
that he thinks that that the videotape
the guy on the videotape is like a real
person that's
talking to him in real time you know
what i'm saying so
he starts getting involved with this
videotape and he keeps watching it over
and over and then like he starts doing
[ __ ] like
at one point on the videotape andy plays
go fish with
the person who's watching the videotape
and
david even goes so far as to like make
it so that his hand is what
andy says it's gonna be he's like oh two
sevens and he's like oh yeah
i have two sevens you know so they can
play because obviously the tape is the
same i reached the single time you play
it
now it happens that when he starts
getting obsessed with the tape it so
happens that he gets matched with a
woman
uh from the video rendezvous thing
and she's like the perfect match right
she's per
she's also a caregiver she works at uh
like a nursing home
so he so she understands like that he
has to take care of his mom and she know
she works with people like that all the
time so she gets where he's coming from
they have a date it goes awesome but
then um
like i said whether it's the videotape
or whether it's just david flipping out
um things start to go horribly horribly
awry with
maybe andy on the videotape not liking
that david now has a girlfriend and
he just wants he just wants david all
for himself i guess
it's like it's a really really it's
weird
but there's something really there was
something really compelling about it and
i think i really really liked the score
i really really liked the whole look of
it
like it looks very much like 1990
uh you know what i mean it's not it
doesn't look like oh it's today and
we're making a movie set back in 1990
aren't we cute
it looked like everything in there was
like 1990 and it was kind of like
the house that he lived in with his mom
it was just super depressing
and his character i think he did a good
job because
i mean will wheaton was [ __ ] great in
this he was like i said he was
overly nice but to to an extent that it
was like really sinister like it started
getting really sinister after a while
but the um brian fogan's character
that very easily could have shaded over
into just being pathetic
and you not you know you being like what
a
pitiful you know specimen but he
actually does a good job at making him
kind of pathetic but also
sympathetic you know what i mean like
you feel bad for him you want
him to have a girlfriend you want him
you know you don't want him getting
sucked into this [ __ ] videotape weird
fantasy that he has going
so it's like you're kind of rooting for
him but then at the same time like when
[ __ ] starts going sideways
so it's almost like i don't want to say
it's sad but it is like it's like a
tragic
story i guess and i think that it
it is that just because the acting was
so good like especially the two of them
there's a couple other characters too
like the mom and the girlfriend and
stuff
but it's mostly just the two of them and
i don't know i just i just really really
liked this i thought it was really
compelling it kind of really kept me it
sucked me right in and just kind of
i was just like riveted the whole time i
was watching it
yeah like i said i only saw about half
of it the last half yeah it was good
and it's yeah because it starts it's i
don't necessarily want to call it a slow
burn i don't
i don't think it was that slow um it's
mostly
but it's mostly like psychological [ __ ]
but then like the last
maybe 15 20 minutes of it goes like
batshit crazy
if you liked joker you'd like this yeah
if you'd like
video drum you'd like this uh it
what else yeah i'm trying to think of
like other things that it kind of
reminded me of things that you
that you'd like if you like those movies
you'd like this one
you know about it probably
yeah i think it's it's interesting too
because i think it was kind of cool that
they said it
back in 1990 and so you have kind of the
whole nostalgia thing
of you know how cheesy like the video
dating services
were and stuff but it's almost like it
could apply to modern day too
like modern day social media just like
in a different format
right so you know what i mean so it's
kind of like universal even though it
had the trappings of 1990 with all the
[ __ ] vhs tapes and all that other
kind of [ __ ]
yeah but if you're into those dead mall
videos like i am an urban exploration
that
it's got that look yeah this will
probably probably be uh
right up your alley like because it's
you know it's just it's a great looking
movie and i think it was like a really
well written movie and the
characterization is really really good
crappy old cars yeah old cars from the
late 70s and 80s 90s [ __ ] driving
around there yeah actually
1990 in 1990 you didn't see many 1990
cars you mostly saw 80s cars
yeah because the 70s cars because a 1990
car was [ __ ] brand new you didn't see
very many of them
well yeah because most people in 1990
couldn't afford to [ __ ] yeah
i think i didn't even buy i didn't even
buy my first car until maybe 1995 or
1996 and it was in 1987.
some of the early early 90s cars
you know like the toyotas and stuff were
just old also 80s cars
dressed up yeah different paint jobs
different accessories on them
you know like the corollas and stuff
look it's the 90s now
it's the future yeah and for like eleven
ninety five you'd still have late 80s
cars in there just kind of [ __ ]
different body panels on them yeah it's
just it's funny when you were living
through it
i i thought that i remembered like as
soon as 1990 1991 hit
because 1990 i graduated from high
school in 1991 like when grunge came in
and all that kind of [ __ ] i don't
remember it still
looking like the 80s i guess i'm still
like perceiving
you know when i think about the 90s or
the early 90s i used to think of like
grunt [ __ ] like
everybody wearing flannel shirts and all
that kind of crap and like everybody
kind of going back to looking like
hippies and whatnot
but then when i see movies from 1990
like everyone's still got big hair and
[ __ ] shoulder pads and like all
[ __ ] neon colors and [ __ ] i'm like
really was that freaking it's like i
don't know
it was a long time it's hard for me to
remember if you look at old video you
know old home video from the late
uh from the 80s mid mid to late 80s
because you know some people have video
cameras especially at
shopping malls and stuff you know 87
86 i forgot how
soviet the [ __ ] united states looked
everything looked really
cheap yeah everything was cheap and ugly
cheap materials squared cheap
manufacturer
everything looked really disposable
disposable consumer
products just samey
just cheap looking clothes everybody
wore cheap looking clothes
something about the materials and the
cuts it just didn't look like i just
remember like all the colors
all the furniture and [ __ ] in people's
houses and like the that
crappy like plasticky wood paneling
[ __ ] yeah and that crappy [ __ ]
the uh the uh the patterns on all the
material for the
for for on the couches you know just
[ __ ] ugh i know everything is
so ghastly i mean
and even real expensive furniture like
the leather and [ __ ] it looked like
[ __ ] too i was never a big fan of those
because i feel like
that was kind of a big thing
particularly in the 80s everybody
if you had a lot of money you had like
those big puffy like leather
couches i never i didn't like those even
back then i thought they were ugly back
then
yeah and then they'd put a [ __ ] nagel
they put a [ __ ] nagel
patrick oh yeah patrick nagel print
behind it and [ __ ] some
stainless stainless steel [ __ ]
floor lamp that came out with a triangle
top on it trying to be all
it was modern modern looking and it just
looked [ __ ]
like something out of a two-bit porn
flick
it did so well and i have to think too
like in my grandma's house
i think sometime in the 80s she got like
some of those puffy
leather cat leather i don't think it was
real leather but it was kind of like
leatherette couches they were white
pleather
yeah i think the reason that maybe it's
because i grew up in florida and all you
can remember
is just your the backs of your thighs
sticking to that [ __ ]
just sweating all over it it was so
gross yeah
that's like all i remember about leather
couches from back in the day
your ass getting all sweaty from like
sitting on it i remember some of the 70s
stuff looking better
than a lot of the 80s stuff yeah almost
like the quality might have been a
little bit better
in the 70s 60s i think it was
yeah four throw down said literally
everyone had a perm
yeah i think they did i i had a perm
until
well i had perms in the 80s but my hair
does not my hair just like wants to be
straight
so i had my great aunt was a hairdresser
and she i used to
every now and then have her come over
and try to do like a ringlet type of
perm because i always wanted like
ringlets
and it's like it would stay for a day
and it would be like woo look it's all
curly and then like the next day it'd be
like
and it would just fall right out i gotta
look back see if anybody studied that
period you know living through it you
know we just kind of took it for granted
but i just remembered that
there was an abundance of stuff but it
was all cheap stuff
yeah so i guess it was there was an
economic boom and a lot of rapid growth
and but it wasn't made out of stuff that
built to last
really it was just made
for high profit and for very low retail
value
you know what i mean so you could buy it
cheap and they could they sold a lot of
it
you know furniture and clothes and it
just everybody thought it was rich but
it was like fake rich
yeah everybody could just [ __ ] you
know decorate let's decorate the [ __ ]
out of this
we're nouveau reese we're gonna decorate
the [ __ ] out of this place
cardboardy looking crap [ __ ] you know
cheap looking linoleum countertops and
stuff oh man i hate it remember those
things
yeah cheap linoleum floor tiling that
would [ __ ] over time would start to
[ __ ]
warp and it didn't really stick right
just yeah everything looked like crap
it looked good when you bought it and
then like two years later it was just
[ __ ] falling apart
yep sad remember don't build whatever
wherever the refrigerators were there'd
be like a [ __ ] warp running around
with a refrigerator putting too much
pressure on it yep yeah i remember that
and then like the heat from the [ __ ]
stove would get to it
warp around and [ __ ] stuff the
broiler
[ __ ] [ __ ] up your linoleum tile
that's why all that [ __ ] went away it
didn't work then they
replaced eventually everybody replaced
that [ __ ] in real tile yeah you can't
get
well you know they sold you to the
fantasy that hey for real cheap we could
cover this whole thing that's just as
good as high tech
yeah just as good as [ __ ] real
[ __ ] tie i'll see you though
not one no plastic sheet on the [ __ ]
floor
yeah pretty much to see if anybody has
remembered
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you kind of had them
you kind of had a mullet a little bit in
the 80s everybody did
yeah everybody did it that was like long
hair
yeah mine was not i don't know if i'd
call mine a mullet
as so much as like in the 80s like when
i was in junior high
i had kind of a shag cut yeah that was
kind of mullet i don't know if i'd call
it a mullet it wasn't like super short
i had that [ __ ] rick springfield
slash [ __ ]
um like an um andrew eldritch haircut
yeah because andrew if you really
analyzed it andrew eldridge's haircut
was [ __ ]
just a long version of rick
springfield's character that was totally
a mullet and it was like
a mullet yeah that's what i had [ __ ]
thought i was a member of the [ __ ]
sisters of mercy
it's really funny because i feel like
the mullet didn't really get
the redneck tag until later in the 80s
because i feel like in the early 80s it
was more like a new wavy looking yeah
it's like a new wave look
you're like oh it's punk rock you know
what i mean but then like as the mid 80s
well what happened was the second the
the wwf
wrestlers started starting to get it and
then
then [ __ ] everybody in the panhandle
and all the dudes of the four by fours
and [ __ ] had that
and then so all the new wave and punk
kids were like okay we can't do it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] just a few years before the lead
singer kenji gugu had
lemal
but now you got rednecks with that
[ __ ] haircut man it's like
ridiculous embarrassing [ __ ] they're
dipping and [ __ ] and got a [ __ ]
peterbilt [ __ ] baseball cap on
looking like joe dirk yeah
oh my god they were what they were yeah
they were funny though man most of those
guys if you if you knew those guys like
my dad [ __ ] my dad's friends were
like that
they were funny they [ __ ] just they
would get drunk in the middle of the day
they'd work they work real hard [ __ ]
yeah rebuild [ __ ] cars
on their own in the middle of the day
back your house [ __ ]
just come up with the craziest [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's where all my beer came from
yeah oh really hold my beer
[Laughter]
what do you mean you can't ride on an
upside down lawn mower i can ride along
while we're upside down
hold my beard you know i'm [ __ ] here
trying to ride on lawn mower in the
[ __ ] blade going his nuts [ __ ]
dangling
[Laughter]
what do you mean i can't shoot an anvil
out of a cannon yeah i can totally do
that shooting anvils out of a cannon we
do that yeah hold my bear
thank you man yeah
thank you thank you very much i mean
that's that's dollar for pastor tom pass
me the gatorade yeah
this people people you know i was lucky
enough to [ __ ]
grow up around real rednecks down
[ __ ] deep south mississippi
all right they're not even really
rednecks they're just [ __ ]
southern [ __ ] super super southern
you know
and the the rednecks that you saw on tv
were imitations of these guys
you know what i mean and then rednecks
up north they had rednecks up north they
got rednecks everywhere they were just
everywhere
they're cut they were copying our
rednecks our rednecks were the originals
we have the og yeah right
you guys are just poser rednecks yeah
and a lot of them if the ones that were
like maybe ten the one the little ones
are a little bit
older that they looked up to the the
rednecks looked up to some guys that
were like 20 years older than them
and those [ __ ] were the
embodiment across between colonel
sanders
and foghorn leghorn they they were
literally
saying i say what boy say ho well hold
on boy
let me hit crackers real [ __ ]
crackers that's exactly what they were
oh hold on hold on
yeah come here and they called everybody
boy
yeah yes siree boy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] hilarious that's like foghorn
they didn't know yeah just like foghorn
leghorn that's what
the [ __ ] gordon was a cracker yeah all
right oh big time
and and as [ __ ] man growing up around
those dudes is a [ __ ] trip man
so you're trying to kind of dress them
funny
[Laughter]
spending too much time in california
with all the fruits and the nuts
come on boy let me show you take them
socks out three cuz then three striped
socks then three
times no we're back in the 70s and 80s
the three stripe socks yeah
yeah yeah fog or lego or get pissed off
you saw you wearing it flying shirts
you're not in hawaii that's mississippi
[Laughter]
you only you almost sounded like sling
blade there yeah yeah
he would have been a cracker yeah use
cracker right french fries
yeah trying to explain some [ __ ] for
some of you
europeans some some of our
african-americans
a cracker is a white guy but they're not
calling him a cracker because
because of white skin white people
called them
crackers they were back in the day they
wore
white suits they were white guys they
were white suits they walked around look
like
and they were cracker jacks like a
cracker jacket [ __ ] looking
like a pimp yeah yeah they were like
glowing yeah
but like the ultimate was the white suit
and you know and that would have been
colonel sanders colonel sanders was a
a kentucky cardinal which was a cracker
he's a great he's just a
he was famous you know you could get a
kentucky
commission as a carnal it's an honorary
title
and they gave that to dudes just because
they look sharp
imagine that that's the way the old
southern culture was that's [ __ ]
crazy think about that
you're dressed up and everybody likes
you so we're going to make you a
cardinal
yeah that's the [ __ ] you're getting
meanwhile
meanwhile real colonels are like real
colonels are in the army
colonel yeah you're just representing
representing white pimpin white it was
white tip
[ __ ] exactly
where they were you know what it's
really funny that one of the
one of the cartoons that i remember from
my childhood was the foghorn legworn
cartoon
it was that one where it was that little
chick with the glasses it was like a
super genius
and uh i still remember that scene where
he
the little chick had like drawn all of
this like formulas and [ __ ] like that
and uh foghorn leghorn was like hiding
where he was hiding in like a dumpster
or a box or something like that and then
he came out but then
you know he's like don't even tell me i
might be in there you know what i mean
it was like it's just a funny funny
cartoon i hope you guys know what i'm
talking about
because i can't remember exactly what
what yeah badger santa had a show called
cracker jack in the in the uk
when you back in the back in the 20s and
30s they'd say somebody was looking
crackerjack
and they were just looking really sharp
now how old is the cracker jacks
it's not candy it's popcorn with like
it's probably twice with molasses or
caramelly type [ __ ] on it is it molasses
yeah the [ __ ] up no it's caramel
caramel popcorn i mean it's dark it's
darker than caramel but
um and it's got peanuts in it too you
used to get at the movies
yeah so you know looking cracker jack
just meant you were looking good i'm
pretty sure they still make that just
short of that [ __ ] to cracker it had
little prizes inside
like little tattoos and [ __ ] and i guess
the white suits too
and the white face and the [ __ ]
looking crack you just look like a
[ __ ] cracker walking around
yeah you look like a gold saltine
[Laughter]
[ __ ] just sitting on the porch
drinking lemonade or a mint julep
[Laughter]
and they dressed older than they were
[ __ ] would be like [ __ ]
30 and they dressed like that they were
already old men i'm here
boy yeah yeah yeah come here boy
come up here come up here come here and
see your uncle
sit down sit [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sit right
here sit right here sit here
sit right chill yeah yeah they did say
cheer jam
sit right here yeah my grandmother yeah
all right are we are we done for the day
i'm starving i haven't like
i haven't eaten anything all day and
it's like 3 30. holy crap we have to go
find some food before i pass out
all right so uh yeah so like i said uh
this is renapal it's on
hulu might be on some other streaming
services check it out but we saw it on
hulu
it's really really good i really really
liked it so check it out if you're into
psychological horror or anything like
that or like kind of retro movies
and uh we'll be back tomorrow talking
about another movie
so thanks everybody for dropping by
thank you mango for the donation
and we'll see you guys tomorrow